tel danger pour la santé quelles
conséquences pour l'environnement
après l'incendié de lusine lubrizol à
rouen les riverains des sites
industriels dangereux sont inquiets on
l'a vu se décaler le nuage après les
passer sur cette maison-là mosan alors
maintenant je me dis javel et tout ça
aussi lusine lubrizol fait partie des
sites encadrés par la directive seveso
créé en 1983 un texte européen destiné à
prévenir les risques liés au site
industriel dangereux et à rassurer les
riverains
même si le dispositif porte le nom d'un
autre accident
celle de l' usine chimique de seveso en
italie en 1976
samedi 10 juillet à lahitte mesa une
réaction servant à produire du tricolore
au phénol s'emballe le réacteur chauffe
les valves de sécurité saute et
plusieurs dizaines de kilos de produits
toxiques ces chats pour cette banlieue
de milan c'est le début du cauchemar
la catastrophe sanitaire marquera les
esprits et particulièrement les
riverains des sites seveso
et si chaque évolution de la directive
européenne vise à rassurer les
populations
certains n'ont pourtant aucune illusion
c'était le cas de cette femme
en 1990 elle vivait à quelques mètres
d'une usine à risque si ça saute tout
saute et ben on peut rien faire la même
façon d'aller hockey ontarien fernand
léger de rester même état d'esprit en
1991 près de l'étang de berre dans les
bouches du rhône
ce que je voudrais surtout c'est qu'on
nous dise la vérité
10 % des entreprises françaises
considérées comme dangereuses étaient
alors installées autour de l'étang de
berre et 36 structure il était classé
seveso la pollution issue de ces usines
préoccupait aussi les riverains ça sans
gaz très très fort et c'est une espèce
odeurs nauséabondes
qui ressemble à de l'oeuf pourri il ya
des jours où les yeux piquent ou la
gorge pic et chaque nouvel incident
renforce les craintes exemple en 2001
après l'explosion de l'usiné azf de
toulouse
les riverains d'un autre site seveso en
normandie s'alarmait parce qu'il ne se
produit au chalut à toulouse ça nous
fait penser encore plus pour nous tous
ces gens là on est nous on est très très
très proches
on est toujours dans les fumées dans les
débrouillards comores à toulouse
d'ailleurs en juin 2015
une nouvelle version de la directive
seveso renforçait encore l'information
au public et l'inspection des sites à
risques mais l' incendie de lubrizol à
rouen a encore une fois ravivé les
craintes
un récent sondage du magazine objectif
gare révèle que 90 % des gardois
s'inquiète des conditions de sécurité
des sites seveso du département
[Musique]